moi je suis originaire du sud-ouest de
poau et après je suis arrivée à Paris je
fais une école de théâtre et voilà je
suis comédienne et je suis maman depuis
15 mois j'ai une petite fille qui
s'appelle céleste je l'appelis céleste
parce qu'elle est arrivée par
l'opération du Saint-Esprit parce que je
pouvais pas avoir d'enfant et j'ai eu
j'ai couché une fois avec un homme une
fois et elle est
arrivé j'avais bientôt j'avais 41 ans
bientôt 42 donc c'était
[Musique]
tardif ah
mais là c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
le destin vraiment je pense que j'ai
toujours utilisé la danse comme un
exutoire ouais ouais donc une force et
euh parce que j'aimais le théâtre
j'aimais tous les arts vivant ouais et
je trouvais que dans la danse mis à part
qu'on chante pas
ben on devient des mimes bien sûr on
peut on peut donner beaucoup dans la
danse beaucoup beaucoup bien sûr